[Music]
yo let me show y'all some madden 23 game
play of me getting cheated man in my
super bowl
my mud super bowl
so i throw this crazy dot right here you
feel me up about to be up two
possessions you know i'm feeling good he
comes down the field real quick you know
sam dies at the dots at the thoughts you
know so he's close to scoring but i'm
not tripping because you know i'm still
up so he draws back he throw this
beautiful diary here boom
make him one position lead
so you know i'm feeling myself i'm like
you know hey
i'm still good you know i got i got the
ball back is two minutes left i'm about
to just two to the club
but nah
nah
madding got some other plans for me
this is crazy i'm heated now i'm like
man ain't nowhere
so the next possession you know i get
down the field i'm feeling good you know
i'm like oh i got me a die right here
you know i'm saying this about to be the
dagger
man
then put his feet in so i'm like all
right
ain't nothing can get worse
man let me tell you
this is crazy
this is how i lost my super bowl
i was undefeated
was doing my thing
and now i have a
crazy